>>TIME NOW FOR OUR FRIDAY
FOLLIES.
LOOK AT SOME OF THE CULTURAL
STORIES JUST BENEATH THE MEDIA
RADAR.
WHAT GOOD WITH THE "ME TOO
MOVEMENT"?
LET'S GET INTO THAT WITH RAYMOND
ARROYO.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> I'M NOT WATCHING.
OSCAR SWAG BAGS.
TELL ME WHAT'S GOING ON HERE.
>> OKAY.
IN THE OSCAR SWAG BAG --
>>TELL ME WHAT THEY ARE.
>> THE ME TOO MOVEMENT HAS CAST
A LONG SHADOW OVER THE OSCARS.
BUT IN THE OFFICIAL SWAG BAG,
$100,000 SWAG BAG, IN IT IS
PEPPER SPRAY TO REPEL ATTACKERS,
BODY ALARMS SHOULD YOU BE
TOUCHED INAPPROPRIATELY, AND
WAIT FOR THIS, A DRINK TEST TO
MAKE SURE DRUGS HAVE NOT BEEN
PLACED IN YOUR DRINK.
IF YOU'RE TRYING TO GET AWAY
FROM THE ME TOO THING AND GET
AWAY FROM SEXUAL MISCONDUCT, WHY
IS THAT IN THE SWAG BAGS?
IT'S A REMINDER THAT YOU MAY BE
ATTACKED AT THE GOVERNOR'S BALL.
>> THEY GET THOSE BAGS WHEN
THEY'RE A PRESENTER OR A
RECIPIENT.
>> THEY USED TO GET TIFFANY'S
STUFF.
THEY USED TO GET GOOD STUFF.
WHAT ABOUT THIS HARVEY WEINSTEIN
STATUE IN THE BILLBOARDS IN
L.A.?
>> IT IS HE IN A BATHROBE. AND
NOW, THE CREATOR OF THIS, A GUY
NAMED PLASTIC JESUS -- I CAN'T
EXPLAIN THE NAME.
HE HAD THIS TO SAY ABOUT HIS
CREATION AND WHY HE BUILT IT.
>> YEAH, WE PICKED THE OSCARS
TIME SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE
THERE'S SO MUCH FOCUS ON THE
AWARDS.
BUT HOLLYWOOD HAS THIS DARK
UNDERBELLY THAT GOES IGNORED OR
IN THIS CASE HAS BEEN COVERED UP
OR WORST.
>> HE'S A COMBO OF THE GRIM
REAPER AND PHANTOM OF THE OPERA.
WHAT IS THAT?
PLASTIC JESUS.
I'M GOING TO LOOK UP HIS WORK.
>> THEY ARE BEING REALLY
ATTACKED FROM ALL SIDES.
THEY'RE BILLBOARDS ALL OVER L.A.
CALLING THEM OUT.
WHEN THE SCANDAL IS BIGGER THAN
YOUR MOVIES, THAT'S A HUGE
PROBLEM FOR THEM.
>> NO ONE WATCHED THE OLYMPICS.
THE OLYMPICS IS WAY DOWN.
EVERYTHING IS POLITICIZED.
>> BUT WHY ARE YOU DOING ME TOO
MOVEMENTS IN THE CEREMONY THAT
IS SUPPOSED TO CELEBRATE IT?
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
THE SCANDAL --
>>I THINK THEY JUST HAVE ONE OF
THOSE DRESSING ROOM COAT HANGERS
AND IT SHOULD JUST BE A WHITE
BATHROBE EMPTY ON THE STAGE,
JUST HANGING BY ITSELF.
>> IF THEY WANT TO BE
SELF-REFLECTIVE, TALK ABOUT THE
MIS
MI
MISOGYNISTIC PROGRAMMING.
THIS NEEDS TO BE TAKEN DOWN.
IT'S AN AFFRONT.
AND TWO COURTS HAVE NOW SAID IT
SHOULD BE REMOVED.
THIS IS GOING TO HAVE TO GO TO
THE SUPREME COURT.
>> IT'S GOING TO BE TAKEN DOWN.
>> WHY REMOVE EVERY VESTIGE OF